[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as our trip to Ghana came to a close i
sat down with Sam to get his thoughts
like this this year of return for me
means like maybe something different
than it does for everyone else coming
because like I'm literally coming home
yeah you know as a kid in Detroit I had
that I was like oh I know a place where
you're not a minority you are the people
yeah so that I think growing up that's
Beth giving me a perspective on life so
coming here it's refreshed like now I'm
there's no way I can let this much time
go again without coming so I'll be here
everything I've been looking for like
houses and apartments out here I think
it's important that I like make sure I
keep a foothold here again yeah you know
if you've got an apartment or a condo
would there be room there for me to stay
for extended periods of time honestly
yes yes honest about this you think I'd
be a good wingman honestly no
well I'm really glad you got to come and
experience this and I'm really happy
that you I was able to come and
experience this with you as well this is
cool yes kids just these children follow
us wherever we go
mm-hmm I also love just the colors they
wear here are the most incredible colors
yeah the women the men the kids
fantastic
like celebrations of life colors mm-hmm
yeah life is to be celebrated they can
get embrace and got a really really well
[Music]
[Applause]